what a busy week we had because we
covered so much ground this past weekend
because we're almost at the midpoint of
this course I thought it would be useful
to summarize some of the key lessons
from the week and really one of the key
lessons from this course that lesson is
very simple it is that our economies
need to continue to encourage and grow
what we call high road firms that are
both good for shareholders and for
employees if we are really to shape the
future of work that works for all the
stakeholders in our economy how can
organizations do this well it starts by
having a debate over the basic values of
the firm and you did that this week you
took on the question of whether this
emphasis on shareholder value or what we
called financialization view of the firm
is really the only way in which firms
can compete and you answered it very
clearly you endorsed firms that should
be accountable to multiple stakeholders
to employees to societies as well as to
their investors and their owners and you
notice that there's a wide variety of
different forms that organizations take
both here in the United States and
around the world and in fact the u.s. is
one of the few countries that emphasizes
shareholder value so heavily you also
noted that it not only varies across
countries but even in the u.s. we didn't
always put such a heavy emphasis on
shareholder value there was a point in
time when we recognized then that CEOs
recognized that they need to have
organizations that address both the
interests of the people who invest in
them who own them but also they were
held accountable to their employees to
their communities and societies so we
had this debate we have to keep that
debate going in the poll let you answer
to vast majority you endorse the
stakeholder view of the firm so let's
get on with it but you also noted that
there's no magic bullet there's no
single practice
that high road firms can follow to
achieve these outcomes instead what we
saw is that there's a bundle of
practices or what we call a system of
practices of employment practices
operational features the organization
business practices that have to fit
together and be fitted to the particular
industries in particular organizational
settings particular cultures and
countries in which they are embedded and
this is just a list of the basic things
that we discussed that yes it starts by
hiring good strong employees who have
good technical skills and good people
and organizational skills so they can
work together in teams and communicate
with each other then we invest in
training and development and make sure
that we create a culture of respect and
Trust at the workplace provide employees
with a good opportunity to improve
operations in the organization to bring
their voice into the discussions so that
their interests are reflected in
organizational practices themselves and
then recognize that you all want good
flexible organizational arrangements
that allow you to mix your personal and
your family and your work lives but to
do it in creative ways with modern
technology with fair wages that are
linked in some ways to productivity to
performance of the economy of your
organizations and where there are unions
involved we need to have strong
partnerships between labor and
management not the traditional
adversarial relations when we do those
things we get this bundle we get this
system of reinforcing practices between
the business strategies that are
followed to create high road
organizations the employment systems the
operational practices and the workforce
culture so we know something about how
to do this and we know that this can
happen not only in traditional
profit-making firms or public
corporations but we discussed a whole
range of different organizational forms
family businesses like Market Basket
public corporations as we mentioned
benefit corporations like Patagonia
employee owned firms like my two
favorite breweries new belgium and
harpoon or in other countries i do in
sweden and around the world there are
examples of employee owned firms
community ownership monde de gran in
Spain and other countries and then my
favorite football team you know the
Green Bay Packers owned by the community
and maintaining long-standing good
relationships with their stakeholders in
their environments we also discussed
whether it's possible for global
corporations to hold to high road
standards in their supply chains we've
got a lot of work to do in this area
it's clear that we have a long way to go
but companies and their suppliers and
NGOs are all working on it so we
recognize we can do this in a variety of
ways but I was particularly excited and
pleased with the examples of high road
and low road firms that you talked about
in your own assignments this week and
you brought your own personal
experiences as employees and sometimes
as customers into this process and
here's just an example of firms in the
retail industry family-owned firm
wegmans that's a local one here in the
United States whole foods which is known
very well was used as an example and
compared with some other organizations
one well-known and another one where we
just disguised the name a bit in another
country that talked about the low weight
low wages lack of a living wage not
particularly paying attention to
employee training and development but
also noting that even in government
agencies you had some very low road
firms or organizations that favored
there certain employees and didn't
provide the kind of feedback and
opportunities for growth but then there
were some libraries hospitals government
agencies that you rated as high road
firms the key point here is there's no
single organizational form and there's
no single model that says you can only
do this in some sectors of the economy
not others so I think we have brought
home this very key lesson about the
importance of high road firms our
challenge now is to make sure that we
figure out how to spread them to larger
numbers so this next week it's time to
go on to the next subject we're going to
take up two critical issues
entrepreneurship and the role of
technology and you've already started
those conversations on the discussion
forum so we'll continue them with some
really good videos and guest interviews
and material from people all over the
world talking about how we can use
technology to augment work not just a
substitute for work or displace work yes
that's going to go on but pay particular
attention to what our experts say we can
do to use technology to good advantage
to augment and to support good work in
the future and then let's also discuss
how we can build high road firms right
from the beginning as entrepreneurs what
do we need to do to make sure that we
understand what it takes to have a good
business model to be responsive to the
investors who are providing the capital
for these firms but also to make sure
that we make the choices about how we
build good jobs and careers for all of
the employees in these new enterprises
and let me make a final offer that is
we're almost about as I said at the
midpoint of the course and I'd like to
use this weekend to offer an open forum
sort of office hours on the discussion
board where my team here for the course
and I will be available to answer
questions to engage in commentary to
continue the dialogue with you more
directly so please take a look at the
discussion board participate with us ask
us questions let's use this as an
opportunity to see what we have learned
so far to continue to debate even with
us if you disagree with us that's fine
too let's have a good discussion this
weekend I'll make sure that I check the
discussion board periodically over the
next several days and see what's on your
mine and then finally this weekend we
will give you a short evaluation to give
to us a favor and give us a mid-course
evaluation on how we are doing in the
course so I look forward to continuing
the conversations this weekend and in
the weeks ahead